[Musique]
me mêler de la vie
si tous kankan est astucieux
johnny fait le plus sérieux à jouer et à
gagner
bonjour fabrice bonjour tous qu'en corse
et il m'a fait une vie qui touche été
obligé de l'amener encore en bas tu as
bien fait mais valérie ne voulait pas me
laisser partir tout seul en bas il a
raison alors dit bonjour et bon bouillon
métier bonjour dit tout wu
bonjour ça va est ce qu'on a fait un bon
bah on va demander à tempère ce qu'on va
faire
alors quand c'est l'expérience oui oui
tu as devant toi tu vois tu as un verre
d'eau et de la très très bonne nous tu
vois il peut tu veux goûter nous allons
pendant non et puis tu as des petites
pièces là dans le petit dans le gobelet
la pièce de monnaie à des pièces
demandées de 5 centimes bon à ton avis
dans ce ver qui est remplie vraiment tu
vas jusqu'au bord un rapport à ton avis
combien peut-on mettre deux pièces là en
principe c'est pas moi aucune parce que
ça va déborder et et bien non il y aura
des noms mais non maintenant il faut
faire alors tu peux en mettre 2 3 4
jusqu'à neuf ou dix pièces sans que ça
déborde
après ça je demande à voir la grande
première tu suis mis conseil weave asie
dans l'assiette on faire tu la mets dans
l'eau par la tranche en salle comme ça
bon alors attention je n'ai mas et
doucement presse du salon at il de
effectivement ça marche qu'elle voudrait
pas paris et bien annulé trois listes
ordinaires et ouais ça va bien 4 c'est
pas croyable
combien de grands maîtres 5,6 attenti
tout bouge pas 7
et ça ne déborde toujours pas vous
voudrez plus tard
non c'est juste la voilà enfin tu vas tu
es convaincu 1 écoutez c'est une 10e et
puis on verra bien mais ça va être
difficile mais j'ai réussi et
déformables
vous voyez et vous pouvez aussi essayer
chez vous c'est étonnant c'est cet agent
était connue mais ce qu'on fait
maintenant
alors maintenant le jeu du le mot tamoa
le mot à mot le mot tu as mis ton leur
ennemi est toujours la même place je
prends mon panier voilà et je vais je
vais là-bas m'asseoir tranquillement tu
t'en souviens bien de ce jeu en du
mot-à-mot oui où on l'a fait la dernière
fois déjà voilà sur le mot à mot avec
les petits cartons qui sont dedans qui
sont dans le panier il ya par exemple
des objets bon si ces objets je te je le
rappelle sont tous des mots d'une
syllabe harcha un phare un bol et cetera
alors quand tu en tires 5 au hasard oui
hein
alors nous allons essayer de fabriquer
des démos de deux trois ou même quatre
syllabes
oui encore que far ça fait deux syllabes
m'enfin konarka main alors à givet au
tableau oui oui la dernière fa dit je
crois bien que c'est moi qui avais gagné
c'est vrai tout cancan ou alors tu as
peut-être envie de prendre sa revanche à
l'arrêt réflexe comprend d'ailleurs les
autres aussi je te signale alors tu
atterris jeu tu tires les cartons
premier carton un rare tu sais ce que
c'est qu'un abri arras et à petit un
petit animal un petit rongeur quand même
un gros d'ailleurs segura à ça c'est un
véhicule assez spécial ça s'appelle un
vent vous savez vancouver2010 les
chevaux les chevaux de course par
exemple que peut pas nous faire le
cheval ah non je ne sais pas faire le
cheval ça c'est très difficile bon ça
c'est quoi ça tout cas encore et ça
c'est quoi c'est un fait c'est 1 1
c'est un homme parfaitement là nous
avons un mort un mât de bateau
enfin là c'est 1 1 par un pas un pan
voilà alors dites moi qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire avec tout ça à ton avis sur
tout moche qu'il n'y ait pas de la pluie
parce que avec pas et orageux
le fai parapluie à bas bruit mais il
n'ya pas parapluie alors y'a pas de
rayons peut pas le faire ça non oh non
je vois pas dit dont la manger j'ai un
problème bien qui répète alors mentir à
dire un sixième carton ah oui parce que
je suis coincé au 6e carabine tu as le
droit j'ai le droit
alors là tout concourt cette année nous
sommes bien d'accord
c'est un n'ait été trouvée m'avait
trouvé
qu'est ce que tu as trouvé mauvais on
pourrait on pouvait le faire dès le
début des paravents paravent bravant
s'applique en boule par avancée
formidable
oui oui oui alors on n'utilise pas et
qui continue famille à toi continue pas
ras et puis van ba voilà comment ça
s'écrit pas du tout de la même façon un
à part avant le mot lui s'écrit comme
cela à mes la nation un oui à brice
limoux ne s'écrivent pas comme il se
prononce alors entendu pas re à vent
voilà voilà d'abord un oui il reste un
match et n'est t juste non un matney
witi encore quelque chose
oui parce que là un matt nix ce qu'on
fasse avec ça voilà une si oui oui carla
jd oui je pourrais je trouver moi je
suis déjà je crois que j'ai trouvé oui
un ainsi signer une séance de ciné tu
m'as donné l'idée fine et cie né à nancy
n'est pas une erreur cinéma cinémas
remercie ses amis mes mains je suis bête
alors sera plus de trouver ça cinéma oui
alors cinéma s'écrie comme cela dit
n'est emma a passé cette date là il ya
deux gagnants de la série les bras roulé
fabrice guy et ben bravo hein ça c'est
bien joué quand même je crois
effectivement piquant bull a été très
brillant lui aussi oui oui c'est une
excellente chose
on vit cambou le tube puisque tu as
gagné tu vas me désire
et dans ce panier une une enveloppe à
quelle enveloppe vu que nous convient
celle là est la brique bord je vais
m'occuper de cette enveloppe
il s'agit de dans le petit vient de
saint-frédéric héros qui habite royal a
atteint c'est une lettre charmante qui
nous est adressé à tous de la part de sa
môman c'est madame héros bonsoir madame
c'est un petit garçon de 8 ans à je
saute l'essentiel il aime beaucoup les
quatre amis c'est une bonne chose
j'aime vraiment la halle
il est ivre a dit ce qu il voudra
district 4 amis l'adisq des cabris la
foule m'a envoyé on lui envoie et on lui
aurait passé d'accord alors les quatre
amis tristement des quatre amis la
chanson avec tous mes petits camarades
c'est d'accord tu va la recevoir très
bientôt voilà à gauche qu'est ce qu'il
ya et qu'est ce qu'il y à rien et
regarde on doit regarder votre porte et
est temps de dresser bush - oui oui ah
oui oui fabrice oui c'est à nous
maintenant
oui tu vas au tableau comme d'habitude
quatre marqueurs le voile alors à nous
deux alors cette fois ci c'est un mot en
onze lettres
alors on est d'accord on joue toujours
avec les france paris je voulais te le
dire alors les animaux les plantes c'est
terminé à 6 les transports 11 uniquement
les transports on commence alors là
c'est encore un moyen de transport assez
particulier d'ailleurs alors onze
lettres
oui oui alors la première lettre la
première lettre c'est un à un à huy pas
si la première lettre
alors je fais 9 très pour le lecteur qui
mens 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 et la dernière
lettre c'est un homme un e
voilà voilà bien alors j'attends tes
questions alors c'est un moyen c'est un
moyen de transport un moyen de transport
alors est ce que c'est un moyen de
transport qu'on utilise sur une route
ils forcent pas spécialement non sur la
mer non plus non non plus non plus sur
des sur des rails
non ya pas de nom alors dans les airs
dans les herbes dans les airs dans les
airs
donne moi une autre lettre une autre
lettre la troisième de tulle à 3 où il
est alors la 3e c1 elle est la halle
elle n'est ni des âmes est ce que je
peux te donner encore un client je vais
t'aider quand même
ah oui parce que je vois pas comment son
parent 1 110 harsard est un appareil qui
commet des régimes ou qui monte et qui
est vertical qui monte à la verticale
tout parce que je veux dire
la band aid and on and on ne me dit pas
ne me dis pas que c'est un hélicoptère
un hélicoptère immonde verticalement
anémique
c'est pas croyable mais enfin tu ne sais
pas qu'elle y kopter s'écrit comme ça
comme depuis le temps qu'on te demande
d'apprendre un petit peu l'orthographe
et lille que chez compliqueront la la la
la cote
il faut que je fasse attention là parce
que je n'ai plus beaucoup de places
hélicoptère qu'il écrivait ayela
évidemment à yale tu écrivais sa
perrinelle la commune la famille disent
quoi les options non ça n'a rien dit moi
non c'est pas là il ya quelque chose que
tu c'est ptet pas week le premier
hélicoptère qu'on a construit c'était un
jouet oui un jouet pour les enfants et à
il a été construit il ya presque deux
cents ans 1 alors tu vois que les jouets
d'effacer ça peut être sérieux tu n'as
pas brusquer jouer avec moi
c'est la cia music bêta qui côtoie cher
fabry oui ma chute en tricotant 2000
doigts de fée je vais te proposer notre
petit jeu musical bon j'étais raconte
une petite histoire laissant certains
mots inachevé toi tu complète c'est mon
haleine des notes de musique que tu
placera sur cette portée musicale
indiqué oui à la fin ces notes formeront
le début de la chanson dans voici
l'histoire comme toujours
alors oui le héros de mon histoire c'est
un monsieur très gentil très courageux à
monsieur qu on reconnaît facilement
grâce à son grand chapeau un chapeau qui
lui permet de ne pas être rapide d'un
dans sa relation sa ration solo c'est
parfait et la spécialité de ce héros
c'est de venir au secours des gens qui
ont des ennuis il n'aime qu'une chose
rendre service
chez lui c'est une m'a dit lana malades
a dit il est toujours bien équipé la son
cheval ses bottes ce pistolet ou
pourrait le prendre pour un mandat à un
soldat un céleri lorsqu'il apprend que
quelqu'un par exemple a été fait
prisonnier par ses senneurs pensez quoi
par ccn un ennemi et de les nommer qui
sait quelqu'un a plus aucun espoir de
s'échapper et qui ne sait plus quoi
faire
ouais ben brik est fabriqué en tu
trouves tu te sens fabriqués alors c'est
vous tous
on écoute les semoirs assainir à mon
avis alors que ce pauvre malheureux
pense que tout est fait fini terminé
totalement l'étape à bout du mans avant
l'humain au sol
devrait pas tricoter et faire tout ça en
même temps la façade feria j'irai
jusqu'au bout
alors quand il n'y a plus qu'une chose
qui pourrait le sauver tu sais ce que
c'est bah non c'est un an rate la mire à
ce miracle se produit mon héros harry et
le malheureux prisonniers est sauvé
peut-être un peu en longueur dans laurie
mais vivant dos le riz alors qu'ils
venaient de sol la sole mi fa sol et ben
oui c'est il s'agit de zorro est arrivé
ça va voyons alors attend toujours le
grand euros je retrouve la muse et y
alors là
[Musique]
au faux pas
avec 102 à quoi c'est la voix tu te fais
c'est un petit peu trop
je suis désolé belval excuse moi je ne
savais pas enfin tu vas te rattraper tu
vas venir chanter avec moi j'arrive
rapide ou ce qu'était de tous en famille
déjà papa d'amy d'étape la 10e place que
la vie majeur s'est désisté et rzeszow
fait des choses mais comme je n'ai pas
de mine war lèveront à faire attention
les quatre amis sont pas décents rudy p
4 ça me sens heureux car il aime la vie
c
tél
[Musique]
sa vie peut jouer aujourd'hui vouloir
devenir amis
e
[Musique]
les